I didn't realize we had this in common
you didn't know this but you just found
out I'm told very recently that you are
an Irishman yeah IIIi did the 23 you
didn't 23andme
yeah the genetic test I did not have to
do that test to find out no no no you
what did you feel Goggins I mean I I
knew that I thought there was some
French in there yeah I thought for sure
there's Neanderthal and I'm from Georgia
so redneck neanderthal like right I
didn't think much past that right but I
did I got I got it back and and I am 7%
Scandinavian which was really surprising
to me but I found out that I was
descendent Wow a descendent of a king
really yeah like a real like a king and
I felt really good about myself for like
a minute until I found out that 30% of
the country comes from this guy named
Niles of the Nine Hostages Niles of the
night yeah yeah yeah and and so I but I
did think that I could parlay this
information into some really cool points
with my my kid I was a seven year old
and and so I I said Augustus you know
because of me you are descendant of a
king now for the Nine Hostages and and
he said so so tell me about this King
what did he do and say well he actually
he took nine people hostage in order to
unite the kingdom and he said well he's
not a king he's a criminal because he
took people hostage in therefore you
should go to jail yeah yeah very much
for passing yeah exactly
shouldn't tell him the whole thing just
yeah King that's what I get into what he
did
you